you did a really sweet thing you
revealed which character you were gonna
play at comic-con because a lot of the
fans were wondering wait who's Alice Eve
going to play and you revealed it in a
really unusual way yeah yeah I thought
it was also very sweet tell us what you
did well you know Iron Fist is a show
that kids also watch so a lot of the
audience at Comic Con were younger and
also this is a universe that the
audience knew way more about than me the
people who know about the Marvel Comics
know everything and so I just decided it
would be nice if there was like a
competition everyone loves a winner and
losers count too and you know I said if
you can guess who I'm playing from the
clues that Jeff our exec gave then you
get a kiss and this kid from Argentina
guessed it so quickly and then I gave
him a kiss on the cheek and I think he
consented I don't know yes no no he was
he had no complaints about it he was
very it was a sweet thing to do yeah
let's just don't do that don't make it a
habit you know it's when you're playing
a character well kiss whoever figures it
out we could go awry how did you get
cast as Typhoid Mary because that's the
I mean it's this is an uncomfortable
story for me the casting director is
Laurie Mayfield and she does all Finch's
movies and I met her once or twice once
or twice and they said oh you know we're
gonna do this thing we're gonna have
Typhoid Mary come into the universe and
you know she's a psychotic killer of men
with multiple personalities and Lorraine
was like Alice Eve get me ours so
flattered wage it was like you know they
went straight to you and then I read
about it and I was like why yeah you
know cuz you're a pure talent now the
the the fit the character in the comics
is quite sexy quite sexy I think we have
a drawing here of yeah Typhoid Mary a
very sexy costume is that direction is
that the direction that you're going in
in this obviously that is my ultimate
destination I mean however I guess like
that for like six years in the late 80s
well if that outfit says one thing it's
practical
you know what you'd be surprised if your
motivation is to seduce men and kill
them that is definitely a practical
outfit okay very good
so I would like to take it definitely in
that direction if she has a future which
I hope she does and I loved playing her
but you know I'd love to explore
different sides of her and definitely
explore you know her powers of seduction
and how she uses them and manipulates
her situations to her advantage and
maybe whether we think that's good or
bad and right but you have some say and
exactly how I mean you can actually make
your case and say like this is how I
want the character to be dressed this is
how I you can have some you know as much
as it's a free country I can make my
case but you know it's not necessarily
gonna be taken but like let's make it
right here and now yeah all right let's
do it
I want you to get the costume you want
that you're comfortable with that's very
important to me
you